in august of 2021 i posted a poll on my
twitter asking you guys who your
favorite spider-man was toby mcguire
andrew garfield or tom holland and
despite not having appeared as
spider-man in about 15 years with over
12 000 votes cast toby maguire came away
with the win and almost 50 percent of
the total vote ouch andrew garfield
people seem to think that these toby
maguire films are the peak of this
character in a live-action sense and so
i wanted to put that to the test by
spending my december leading up to the
release of no way home reviewing every
live-action spider-man film in the
modern era to give you guys some context
i hadn't seen these films since they
were in theaters so for those of you
that aren't counting that's like 20
years in the case of spider-man 1. i
loved these films when i was 10 years
old but now that i'm a tired and jaded
30 year old man i want to see if these
actually hold up in my research for this
video i watch each and every one of
these films about six times this
includes the director and actor
commentary i also went ahead and watched
all of the behind the scenes stuff
interviews and shows on youtube all in
all by the time i got around to writing
this video i had actually watched about
30 hours worth of content in preparation
was 90 of it a waste of time absolutely
but hey i found this clip of toby
mcguire getting roasted on live
television did you get out of shape
because i saw some pictures of you
looking quite
poorly
pretty sure you just called me fat okay
i know i joke but i've gone to all this
trouble because i wanted to make a video
worthy of this character worthy of the
cultural icon that spider-man has become
and to explore my feelings towards these
films to see if they have more to them
than i remembered i'm totally not mark
and this is my review for the incredible
the spectacular the iconic sam raimi
spider-man trilogy
[Music]
when i was a kid this was my favorite
film ever until spider-man 2 came out
back then i could sit back relax and
allow sam raimi and toby maguire to take
me on a ride the likes of which would
encourage me to look at films as an art
form in the future i related intensely
with sam raimi's peter parker in more
ways than i'd care to mention aunt may
felt so similar to my grandmother it
hurt whenever she was threatened and i
felt both empowered and captivated by
the final act of this film where toby
mcguire had to face a lunatic that tried
to force him to make a sadistic choice
between saving children and the love of
his life but back then the most boring
part of the film for me was the
beginning before he got the powers back
then i didn't really think the show
started until spider-man showed up and
no not that one this one seeing these
scenes not only cemented my good time as
a kid but forced me to go see the film
four times in theaters much to my mom
and dad's dismay however when i went
back to look at this film i noticed that
my opinions had completely changed i
still love it perhaps more so than i did
before but for entirely different
reasons the first difference being i now
love this opening act far more than i
did before
peter may introduce my father norman
osborne i've heard so much about you
great honor to meet you sir the origin
story broadly speaking this is a story
about two characters primarily peter
parker and norman osborne as they both
grapple with surprisingly similar
philosophical dilemmas side by side
suddenly becoming endowed with power and
responsibility peter inadvertently and
norman purposefully what made this
original comic's run so effective and
the theme of responsibility in it so
potent was peter parker's natural
aversion to it in those comics he came
across as a victim of bullying yes but
also someone that would become a bully
if he had the power to do so and in many
ways he did so once he became spider-man
and it's that very quality which makes
his uncle ben moment so powerful and
more broadly the theme of responsibility
so perfect for this character because
he's not someone that naturally would
adopt responsibility he suffers from a
host of character flaws that run counter
to that philosophy very few of which are
demonstrated by sam raimi's version of
the character in this film toby
maguire's peter parker is shown to be a
quiet but pleasant guy that actively
avoids confrontation at all costs there
are of course elements of that original
urge to take advantage of that
responsibility particularly in the
wrestling section which in and of itself
is a direct homage to the comics but
outside of that it takes the promoter
being totally unreasonable to force
peter parker into making the wrong
decision and while right now it might
sound like i'm pointing out a flaw in
this film it's actually the opposite
this
is perfect as i mentioned peter parker
isn't the only main character of this
film there is another but you can't do
this to me
you know how much i sacrificed
instead of leaning entirely on
spider-man grappling with the theme of
responsibility sam raimi instead
utilizes the norman osborn character to
create a natural contrast that conflicts
directly with the decisions and actions
of peter parker which i think more than
makes up for that difference seen in the
comics and works perfectly for a movie
narrative format while we get to enjoy
the coming of age naivety issues and
hijinks associated with a young man
coming to grips with his new powers
norman osborne too begins exploring his
own new abilities in a sense leading to
both of them being faced with
consequences of their actions peter with
uncle ben and norman losing control of
his company and this is the important
part the beginning portion of this film
shows both of these characters stories
progress side by side and it's at this
crossroads this exact moment that these
two characters take different paths that
ultimately decide who they're going to
become for the rest of their lives with
every subsequent decision made by peter
allowing osborne to look more evil and
vice versa
crap
crap mega crap the costume okay look i'm
going to put my hand up here now and say
this is going to be a hot take and i
appreciate that not everyone is going to
share my opinion on this one but here
are my thoughts i know the tobey maguire
spiderman suit is loved by many and i
used to love it as a kid in fact i used
to draw it religiously it was my
favorite part of the film however now as
an adult i've found my opinion has
changed considerably and perhaps not for
the reasons you might think it's not
because i specifically prefer any other
live-action spider-man adaptation of the
costume in fact i don't think any suit
has really gotten it spot on instead
it's that i don't necessarily like the
design philosophy of these suits and
what they stand to take away from the
performance of the actors beneath them
let me just say right off the bat that
this suit looks really cool and it looks
just as cool as i remember it however i
think that's part of the problem not
because it's cool but more so because it
seems like the cool factor was
prioritized over what the costumes stood
to offer the story for example many
might not know this but underneath every
single spider-man mask in these films
whether it be garfield holland or in
this case toby is another hard face
shield or helmet not for safety or
anything but to create a uniform shape
to the head this has practical benefits
that allow stuntmen to use the suit and
not look dissimilar to the actor however
whenever toby attempts to talk or emote
while inside this suit it feels
emotionless or stilted the elevator
scene in spider-man 2 is a prime example
of this it works as a scene because of
how it's written but it doesn't look
like toby is speaking at all as we can't
see even his mouth or jaw move there are
countless scenes in this film and indeed
this trilogy where the suit prevents an
otherwise emotional reaction or
performance from toby there are plenty
of scenes where the green goblin dock or
even sandman perform reprehensible acts
or threaten his loved ones and the suit
just mutes the performance i think
forcing him in scenes where children and
mary jane are in mortal danger to react
and emote in the exact same sort of way
he would in that elevator scene there's
no expression and when you fast forward
to nowadays it's helped a bit by cgi but
we also get closer to a cartoon's
interpretation of the character with the
fluctuating eye shapes all of this has
been praised as a fresh idea and i agree
that it has lots of upsides it
definitely helps to solve the problem i
spoke about earlier concerning a lack of
emotion however i think this is akin to
putting a bandage over a wound that
really doesn't need to be there for me
the most interesting and uplifting
aspect of spider-man is and always will
be the struggle that takes place behind
the mask the humanity in the character
when peter's hand gets raised and his
name gets called out by the ring
announcer after the wrestling match we
can see his smile through the creases in
that cheap mask he's created now
something to be clear about is that i
don't want a recreation of the mask that
he wears during this wrestling section i
mean that looks awful but i think
there's a happy medium to be met here
with the philosophies of both i mean
just look at any of the artwork of
spider-man by alex ross he goes to
tremendous effort to make sure that you
can see the mouth nose and features
beneath the mask because that's the
important part we get to see the
performance it tells us so much about
the character emotionally that he loves
this sense of power and adulation from
the crowd he's never gotten it before
and that speaks to the actions he takes
right after this sequence of the film
replace that mask with the helmet we get
later and what it looks cool spider-man
the most human of all the superheroes at
least to me
loses a lot of his humanity
these are the years when a man changes
into the man he's going to become the
rest of his life
just be careful what you change into
the lesson
every single one of these films has a
lesson to be learned and this one is the
most fundamental one of the reasons why
i love norman osborn and peter parker's
relationship early is because i
genuinely believe that these words of
affirmation sincerely meant something to
peter throughout this film practically
everyone to an almost comical level
expresses disinterest or negativity
towards peter parker whether it be the
bus school or outside in the real world
but norman at every turn expresses not
just positive affirmations unto peter
but treats him with respect dignity and
helps him to feel proud of himself in
many ways he acts like a father figure
for this troubled young men and to
reinforce this point right after his
conversation with peter parker at the
graduation the next scene shows peter
sitting alone crying that his uncle ben
couldn't be there to see him graduate
there's a gaping hole in peter's life
now for a father figure a mixture of
guilt and longing and every single time
osborne tries to reach peter parker he
does so while building him up in ways
that peter doesn't get from many other
people the lesson of with great power
comes great responsibility is one that
he learns following his uncle's death
however he doesn't truly start to
understand the scope of that mission
statement until the goblin comes along
with a certain proposition
in spite of everything you've done for
them eventually they will hate you why
bother
this is the most important question
norman asks peter in this entire film
and in effect their answers to this
question are what makes their characters
so different the goblin's answer to this
question is obvious but thanks to the
way sam remy built up that character in
the first act we have a small bit of
insight into why he might think this way
but you can't do this to me
i started this company unlike the rest
of the world norman sees spider-man as
his kin someone that unlike the rest of
the world that has betrayed him he sees
himself in which also goes a long way in
explaining why he treats his son like
he's nothing and why he shows interest
in peter because he sees peter as
someone that's exceptional just like him
in this film norman is betrayed by his
friend max and the board members they
are people looking to take advantage of
him and what he's built therefore
they're not worth consideration
furthermore harry his son doesn't
demonstrate any exceptional qualities
unlike peter and therefore he thinks
nothing of him which his relationship
reflects and finally even to norman mary
jane is just another one of those
unremarkable individuals that uses
people for everything they've got before
spitting them out just like his wife did
just like his friends did in spite of
everything he thinks he's done for them
eventually they've all turned against
him and this olive branch goblin is
extending represents an alternative for
peter a philosophy that acts as a
perfect opposite to what uncle ben tried
to instill within him peter doesn't
believe it at first but eventually the
city thanks to some spectacular
journalism on behalf of j jonah jameson
starts to turn on spider-man eventually
learning to hate him
[Music]
on the topic of the city spider-man
saves so many people in this film
something a lot of modern superhero
films i think failed to demonstrate
instead choosing the focus on the
superhuman side of the coin rather than
the hero that defines the genre and in
essence it's that which is necessary for
us as an audience to see spider-man as a
hero first and foremost personally i
think part of the reason why these films
are so quotable is due to their
intentionally colorful and at times
melodramatic scripts they aren't afraid
to sound hokey or corny embracing
everything about these characters to
immerse them in a world that feels both
distinct and fun and personally i think
that's the trilogy's greatest strength
everyone from the main character to mary
jane to the supporting characters to
even the background extras
sounds hot the daily bugle is a terrific
example of this in the film specifically
only one of these characters needs to be
characterized in the way that he is to
drive public opinion of spider-man down
but within seconds of meeting him
courtesy of a legendary performance by
jk simmons by the way were introduced to
not one but three other characters in
the building all with distinct
motivations and personalities that
bounce off each other in spectacular
fashion a technique that will be used to
great effect in the sequel films too and
as a direct result of these films
embracing this corniness we enjoy
countless rich and engaging characters
resulting in this iteration of new york
city feeling alive finding beauty in
some of the darkest and most unlikely of
places i want to spend time in this
world i want to see that weird blonde
guy in the subways singing that strange
but catchy spider-man song i want to
have a weird conversation with some
stranger on the elevator i want to talk
to bruce campbell that seems to be
bouncing from job to job across all of
these films there's so much life in them
and in many ways in peter's pursuit of
living his life in new york city and
doing the right thing we continuously
learn more and more about the best
supporting character in all of these
films the city of new york itself
however in the process of doing the
right thing it leads goblin directly to
peter and by extension
the people he loves most
watching this scene no matter what age i
am will always and forever give me
chills goblin and spider-man have both
been built up to be examples of
diametrically opposed ideologies and
right here we see the natural conclusion
to everything the goblin has been saying
to peter right here the goblin asks
peter an impossible question and somehow
he finds the answer peter's relationship
with mj in this film feels slightly
awkward but in a sort of genuine and
endearing way kirsten dunst's
performance of mary jane carries with it
an endearing authenticity toby does
perfectly fine in the unassuming nerdy
type that doesn't know how to say
something correctly but kirsten
perfectly pulls off the sweet girl next
door with a demon in her closet i want
to talk more about mary jane for sure
but i'm going to save it for later in
this video
you mess with one of us you mess with
all of us
new york proves once again why it's one
of the best characters in these films
the city that once turned its back on
spider-man came to his rescue the
sadistic choice that green goblin
offered peter had an answer and his love
for mary jane wasn't his weakness but a
strength
this is what i mean about the mask being
a limiting factor in these films this is
an emotionally rich scene where the
themes of the struggle between good and
evil finally come and bear their fruit
anger fear struggles sadness confidence
all of this is on display through the
torn and tattered mask of peter parker
in this simple but brilliant fight scene
and it wouldn't have been possible if it
was a helmet everything from the set
design to the choreography is a
goosebump-inducing affair with peter
fighting off the back foot as soon as
goblin threatens mary jane boom he finds
the strength not to defeat the goblin
not to solve all of his problems but he
found the power because he wanted to
protect her from this monster before him
and again perfectly in character as soon
as peter gains the upper hand and norman
can no longer fight he removes his mask
to reveal to peter for the very first
time his true identity peter is shocked
one of the only people who didn't make
him feel worthless who made him feel
impressive and powerful is the green
goblin for the duration of this film in
almost every scene he shares with peter
the goblin has been trying to pry the
ideals of uncle ben from him and in a
last desperate and pathetic attempt to
manipulate peter he pushes that button
to buy himself some time i've been like
a father to you
[Music]
be a son to me now
the two father figures in his life are
telling him two completely different
things to deny responsibility and look
out for himself and to accept
responsibility in order to protect those
that need protection one of those
decisions is easier gives him freedom
and may even come with a father figure
itself but what i think makes this scene
so damn powerful is that throughout this
film norman is proven wrong time and
time again new york saved him when he
was at his most vulnerable mary jane
empowered him when he was at his weakest
and ben parker was and always will be
his father i have a father
his name was ben parker
peter parker has chosen to lead a life
of responsibility and goblin knows that
god speaks spider-man
the story of the first spider-man film
was one that captioned my heart and mind
as a child and going into this re-watch
this retrospective review i was worried
that i wouldn't feel the same magic and
in a way i didn't there's no way for me
to relive these films the same way i did
when i was a child and honestly i'm okay
with that because now i have an entirely
different experience and appreciation
for this film that clearly had so much
blood sweat and tears not to mention
passion poured into it by the cast crew
and the director sam raimi himself it's
a captivating coming-of-age tale
chronicling the importance of
responsibility against tremendous forces
of light and dark and to think they not
only managed to make a better sequel but
an infinitely better secret
[Music]
it's not enough to just
want it it's not enough to
wish or to dream it's not enough to be
good enough you gotta be more you've got
to triumph
every day in the long journey that leads
to synergy you gotta have what it takes
to incentivize the toughest challenges
time comes for everyone
are you just gonna lie down and wait
or are you gonna take a stand
against the world
and consume products
give mark your money
give me your money not only is it
possible for you to challenge and
determination of perseverance on the
path to success and the endurance of
tenacity and faith but you will you will
fight you will battle and you will
courage for momentum and initiate to the
bone
time to get to work
g-fuel
influence
spider-man 2. spider-man 2 is everyone's
favorite film from this trilogy it was
my favorite film when i was 12 years old
and upon revisiting it for the purposes
of this review i can confidently say
that it was way way better than i
remembered it being here's why
[Music]
raising the bar before the creation of
this film spider-man 1 was arguably the
most successful and most critically
acclaimed superhero film at least in
recent memory it captured the hearts and
minds of a generation and even within
the director's commentary for the first
film jk simmons and toby were hearing
rumors of a sequel in the works and it
wasn't until later in behind the scenes
interviews that we learned that raimi
pretty much went from working on the
first film to the second without delay
the point is the first film really
worked and sam raimi had clearly tapped
into something few others before him had
which must have come as a relief to sony
who had been planning for this film
since at least 1998 and i say that
because apparently david fincher had
approached sony with the ambition for
creating an edgier spider-man flick in
1999 starring edward norton as a jaded
and older peter parker there were
sincerely some interesting ideas for
this film but given the landscape
surrounding the first film's release i
think it's easier then to see some of
the reasons why raymies was successful
and why finchers never got off the
ground remy's offered an uplifting
inspiring and hopeful message to america
and the wider world following those
attacks which is why i think this scene
where new york jumps in to protect their
city was so powerful and cathartic but
the question was could sam raimi equal
or better his prior efforts and if he
could then how well within these three
films there's a fascinating attention to
detail concerning their themes and
morals in spider-man 1 peter struggles
to resist the urge to take revenge on
uncle ben's killer in spider-man 2 he
struggles to make the necessary
sacrifices for the betterment of others
and even in the third film when offered
more power and a way to make his job
easier he struggles to let go of that
and in the process literally and
emotionally cripples both himself and
those most important to him looking at
things like this it's clear to see the
road map that sam remy was shooting for
particularly with spider-man 2. but a
message is only clear when you see both
sides at the coin willem dafoe's
portrayal of the green goblin in the
first film has been praised rightfully
as a sadistic and twisted adaptation of
the comics his performance while
appropriately camp and menacing also
clearly depicts quite literally a man at
odds with himself until finally it leads
to his own demise however in spider-man
2 a similar philosophical argument is
made with a much more nuanced center
than the comparatively black and white
good versus evil between spider-man and
the green goblin enter dr otto octavius
a genuine man endowed with the gift of
intelligence he intends on using for the
good of the world a person who by all
accounts is pleasant to those around him
something i don't think could be said
generally speaking about norman osborn
who as i pointed out clearly neglected
his child emotionally and had personal
hang-ups over his past relationships in
short otto is a more righteous person
than norman which is a fascinating point
from which to build a villain from a
choice that i think elevates this film
to hide seldom seen in the superhero
genre and absolutely deserving of the
praise this movie received similar to
norman osborn in the prior film otto
octavius enters the story as a friendly
face to peter parker thanks to an
introduction from his best friend harry
while the relationship between norman
and peter in the prior film felt rich
with plenty of connective tissue and
symbolism at the end alluding to peter's
uncle ben otto octavius doesn't share
such connections to peter and due to
that fact you might believe their
relationship and dynamic within this
story might not live up to defoe's green
goblin and well i can see that line of
thinking in a way but i see a much more
potent visceral connective tissue
through their shared philosophy while
norman osborne in the prior installment
shared a relationship with peter and in
a sense and admiration for him he didn't
share at all the philosophy that peter
learned to value which reimy ended up
using to the film's strength telling the
story of one person who denied
responsibility versus one who embraced
it and so what makes otto octavius
interesting in this film and i'd argue
the best villain in the sam raimi
trilogy isn't that he disagrees with the
philosophy of responsibility in fact
it's quite the opposite actually he
agrees with it well being brilliant is
not enough young man you have to work
hard
intelligence is not a privilege it's a
gift
and you use it for the good of mankind
this is why i love this character and
why i love this film while it has the
best action in the trilogy and some of
the most poignant monologues in i think
cinema history it also manages to be a
master class in dramatic frameworks and
narrative cohesion for in that one short
blink and you miss it portion of their
very first interaction otto offers peter
the answer to every single problem these
two meet in this film which makes what
happens to otto all the more tragic and
believable for just like peter in this
film otto is fallible and has a focus on
his own self-interest
the power of the sun
in the palm of my hand
in sam raimi's spider-man 2 he explores
what happens when you try to uphold one
philosophy while losing yourself to
other negative and indulgent parts of
yourself otto looks at what he's created
a successful fusion reaction something
he's worked alongside his loving wife to
fully realize in order to he says help
mankind but in a quiet moment of
self-reflection instead of thinking
about what he made this for mankind he
instead focuses on the vanity of the
achievement the power of the sun in the
palm of his hand this is otto's ego and
proof that while the arms do gain
influence over him this part of his
personality was always there it's what
started all of this he wants to feel
powerful he's prideful of his own
intelligence which in turn has offered
him immense power and when things start
to go wrong in the process of this
fusion reaction instead of doing what's
best for mankind instead of giving up
this power that he clearly loves he
throws caution to the wind risking
everything to salvage his life's work
and as we've come to realize
his ego and with this decision to
embrace his ego leading to his wife's
death
[Music]
peter's struggle while the first film
was all about accepting that
responsibility this film explores what
it's like to live with that
responsibility throughout this film
peter parker is faced with a cruel
reality that he can't live his life how
he wants as peter parker if he is to
accept the responsibility that's been
thrust upon him as spider-man he can't
have both and when faced with a series
of relatable and harsh circumstances
that bring his social professional and
eventually secret life into ruin he
starts to resent this responsibility he
has he starts to wish that he wasn't
spider-man
before watching this film i remembered
clear as day the struggles peter goes
through towards the start in fact out of
all the films outside of the bombastic
moments these scenes were what really
stood out to me as a 12 year old kid at
that age people started to ask me
questions like what i wanted to do with
my life a question i didn't have an
answer for when i was 22 let alone when
i was 12. i knew my family had money
troubles and above all else i was
entering my teenage years where i knew
new schools friends and obligations
awaited me it was very much a formative
time in my life and this film deals with
that in a very visceral sense that scene
where aunt may gives peter 20 for his
birthday and he tries to give it back
because she needs it more than him hits
so close to home for me that i can't
help but be moved by rosemary harris's
performance every single time and now as
an adult looking at this film i resonate
with peter even more going to the bank
with aunt may only to be disappointed
getting fired from his job because he
needed to focus on other more important
things struggling to make rent
dissolving relationships
misunderstandings leading to resentment
amongst his friends these set pieces and
scenes are written to effectively bury
peter parker beneath a seemingly
never-ending avalanche of negativity
failure and sorrow because we need to as
an audience feel the same way or relate
to these issues he's having in order for
the story to work in order for this
scene to work as a kid watching peter
parker walk away from his suit in an
alleyway it felt awful even after being
followed by that raindrop's upbeat
montage showing peter parker doing well
in school seeing mary jane's play and
having time for aunt may still around
every corner were the responsibilities
he was choosing to ignore until he found
one that he couldn't ignore any longer
[Music]
many people might watch this film and
think the burning building scene was the
first instance where peter started to
become spider-man again but in reality
it's in this scene with aunt may
shifting the burden of responsibility
for uncle ben's death from her unto
himself confessing to her that he was
the one responsible for his death it's
an emotional scene with great
performances particularly by rosemary
harris once again as she struggles to
unpack the revelation that just unfolded
before her and this is all to say that
at this moment in time peter realizes
the importance of what he is that he
needs to put other's needs before his
own which is exactly the opposite of
what happens to doc ock
a hero in all of us
i'm not sure if this is a controversial
take or not but rosemary harris's
performance as aunt may is the single
best performance across all of these
films bar none better i think than toby
maguire's kirsten dunces william defoes
alfred molina's or anyone else's
performance in this universe and that's
not the takeaway from any of them they
all did a tremendous job but this aunt
may character presents a quiet but
loving sincerity all wrapped up in a
delivery so warm and comforting that i
moved to tears in almost every other
scene she plays a part in she's the most
loving and supportive person in these
stories and is specifically in this film
the shining beacon that manages to
inspire peter and help him resolve his
internal conflict
in this scene she's his hero throughout
this film peter has been rejecting and
resenting a side of himself beside that
spider-man the side that has
responsibility the side that uncle ben
fought to try and instill and decide
that aunt may reminds him that people
need
where is he henry and i agree
we don't see his picture in the paper
anymore
he
uh
quit i'm not going to mince words here
at may's hero's speech to peter is i
think the single greatest piece of
spider-man dialogue ever put to film
representing in a concise and powerful
fashion everything this character meant
to me as a kid and even me now as an
adult spoken through the point of view
of a character that in effect is in the
process of losing everything that's
meant anything to her she's lost her
husband blamed herself for it is in the
process of losing her home the place
where she lived with ben and most
recently had to come to terms with the
reality that her adopted son peter was
the reason for her losing ben in the
first place when you put it all together
like that it reframes everything she's
saying to peter as something that's not
only being offered as advice but coming
from our own lived experiences this
scene for one reason or another is
powerful to millions of people but for
me upon re-watching this film recently
it hit me in such a way no other film or
indeed story has ever affected me and
there's a particular part to this that i
resonate with most and it's this
everybody loves a hero people line up
for them cheer them scream their names
and years later they'll tell of the day
they stood in the rain for hours just to
get a glimpse of the one who taught them
to hold on just a second longer
i believe there's a hero in all of us
i can't begin to describe what that
means to me today it's been no secret
that over the last two years the world
has collectively endured some uniquely
horrible things isolation loneliness
loss with friendships dissolving and
conflict being the order of the day
every day
in march of 2020 i lost my grandmother
to cancer it came out of nowhere and we
couldn't have the funeral she wanted i
didn't even get to say goodbye it
happened so fast a few months later i
really started to struggle with the
series of lockdowns that my country
imposed months of isolation and then
my dad got sick
very sick
i wanted to be and was there for my
father but having to watch on as someone
you once viewed as invincible being
reduced to a shadow of themselves
frightened and crying for help is in
every sense of the word a difficult
patch to get through and something that
honestly terrified me thankfully my dad
pulled through and is on the mend now
however following those series of events
i felt and anxiety now i was terrified
of my own looming death in the future
something i never worried about before
suddenly made me feel so anxious i
routinely felt myself on the verge of a
panic attack i didn't know what to do i
went to see a psychologist it helped
greatly but what can you really say to
someone who's scared to die
but then i saw this film and i don't
care how this might sound but i needed
to hear what sam raimi alvin sargent and
rosemary harris had to say in this scene
telling me that there's a hero in all of
us that keeps us honest strong noble and
allows us to die with dignity spider-man
2 as crazy as it sounds is a film that i
needed and one that represents the
reason why i connect to and find
filmmaking and more specifically the
character of spider-man so inspiring i
needed him as a kid and now as an adult
i found that once again i needed him to
become steady again to be there for
those that needed me nothing i can say
will ever do justice to what this film
and this scene means to me but i hope
that this at the very least helps to
capture at least a small glimpse of that
spider-man
was a hero
just
couldn't see it
he stole my suit
i want spider-man
[Music]
the train fight the train fight sequence
between doc ock and spider-man is iconic
in fact it's so iconic i'm going to use
it as an excuse to talk about the action
across the trilogy as well as the train
fight itself what becomes immediately
apparent while watching these films was
that while the cgi in places looks a
little janky for a film series produced
in the early 2000s i standing in 2021
and blown away by how so many of these
shots hold up i know high top films
covered this in his review of the action
but i think it's worth repeating for the
sake of this point sam remy was
dedicated to making this film feel real
whenever we get a shot of something in
cgi more often than not it's followed up
by a practical effect or intersperse
with live action elements furthermore
there's a wonderful attention to the
color scheme of this film many of the
fight scenes feel like they're being
shot during golden hour everything from
the scenes the covers of the dvds look
uniform soft around the edges and above
all else more often than not realistic
enough to suspend my disbelief which
brings me to this train fight kicking
things off i love the transition from
peter parker swinging to mary jane's
rescue to the close-up of dr octopus's
sunglasses reflection i do however have
one issue with this fight and the fellas
over at mr sunday movies pointed this
out and to be honest since they pointed
it out i can't unsee this if spider-man
can do this and this
or this
then every single time he punches doc
ock even if i'm taking into account that
peter's pulling his punches for otto's
sake he still should be capable of
knocking him out otto's just a guy with
robot arms a smart guy but still just a
regular human being but yeah that's the
only nitpick i have for this fight and
honestly i don't even care that much
about it because the choreography is
spectacular there's such a delicate
finesse to how spider-man moves and is
animated in this fight scene navigating
both his surroundings and the arms of
doc ock with some of my favorite aerial
acrobatics on show in this encounter
like him being thrown at the bridge but
managing to thread that needle and slip
through the architecture they fight on
the building in the sky on top of around
and inside the train always utilizing
everything at their disposal seeing
stuff like spidey swinging around a pole
inside the train using it to launch
himself out the window and then catch
himself using his webbing just tells me
the folks that orchestrated this fight
were having the times of their lives
there's absolutely no stone left
unturned and it more than shows and most
importantly never loses sight of what
spider-man prioritizes over everything
else
saving people
you have a train to catch it's here
during the chaos of this situation doc
ock has created that the strengths of
this raimi verse can be seen peter
parker some kids cycling through and
trying various ideas as they come to him
in a panic to save these people knowing
that they're effectively hurtling
towards their deaths if he can't stop
this runaway train and what makes this
scene work i think is that dedication
raymie had in giving the civilians of
new york city their own personalities as
spider-man tries to stop this train with
his mask off once again by the way
notice how the people inside the train
talk with him and express themselves
this is vital as it shows us what's on
the line compare that specific element
of this film to spider-man homecoming
sinking ship scene and the difference is
emphatic in this train we see hear and
get to know these people whereas in
homecoming
we don't
they're just people non-descript people
and that creates a massive difference
for an audience in this we watch a hero
redline himself push himself past his
limits all to give these real people
we've gotten to know a chance at
surviving and when he succeeds the
unthinkable happens
spider-man
kids like henry need a hero
courageous self-sacrificing people
setting examples for all of us
togetherness
unity the sense that we're all in this
together trying to support each other
it's such a powerful message of hope and
trust and not wanting to give up your
faith in humanity and as doc ock arrives
on the scene to clean up the scraps once
again they are there to support and
protect each other with all they've got
it's an incredible scene that speaks to
the speech aunt may gave moments earlier
peter became that courageous
self-sacrificing someone that awakened
the hero in all of them it's an
incredible watch and honestly i don't
know how or if it will ever be topped
the climax spider-man 2's greatest
strength is in how it highlights
embraces and thrives in the differences
that exist between otto and norman
osborne unlike osborne part of otto
still believed in that philosophy that
intelligence is a privilege to be used
for the good of all mankind which if you
haven't already noticed is effectively a
rewording of with great power comes
great responsibility you once spoke to
me about intelligence that it was a gift
to be used for the good of mankind
a privilege
peter parker as a hero not only saves
mary jane in this scene from doc ock but
otto also by being courageous righteous
and by trying to do the right thing
peter brought otto back from the brink
reminding him that his intelligence was
a privilege to be used for the good of
mankind and that sometimes to do what's
right we have to be steady and give up
on the things that we want the most even
our dreams encouraging octavius to not
be defined by the worst parts of himself
to not die a monster and ultimately
helped him become another one of the
heroes in this story perhaps even the
main hero of this story sacrificing
himself to stop his own plan in order to
altruistically save everyone in new york
including spider-man in this film we
started out with two heroic figures with
a strong sense of responsibility brought
on by the gifts they both possessed both
were placed under tremendous pressure
and incentive to abandon that
responsibility in order to indulge in
what satisfied them personally no matter
what they ended up sacrificing by making
that choice thankfully however due to
the good one of them did during their
time spent embracing that responsibility
they managed to bring out the hero in
others enough to inspire themselves once
again while the other never managed to
crawl out until it was too late until
too much damage had been done auto
octavius is a tragic example of what
happens when someone who once tried to
uphold a particular ideal fails in doing
so one that demonstrates that even if
you have a change of heart if too much
hurt has been caused then there's
nothing left to salvage
and that in accepting this reality when
one needs to
after all this suffering
in the end
it's always worth it
call deborah
tell her not to open the caviar
spider-man 3
this might be a hot take but i think the
real reason people didn't like this film
when it came out not years later in
video essays but when it came out
largely was due to how the script
treated the character of venom in a
number of behind the scenes extracts
from this film as well as some of the
commentary tracks they explained how
popular the character of venom was to
the fan base and later in interviews how
unpopular he was with sam raimi well
okay that's a bit of a stretch i don't
know if he actively didn't like the
character or not but what i do know is
that venom wasn't a character raimi
himself resonated with or grew up with
and so there wasn't any drive to make a
film starring him as a main villain and
unfortunately this is where the divide
between raymie and his audience was the
most pronounced in these films and i can
attest to that at the time this movie
was being made 2006-2007
i was their target demographic and at
the time i didn't know and to be honest
still don't know anyone that's gone back
to read the original run of the comics
which in and of itself is a tragedy at
the time everything my friends and i
knew back then about spider-man came
from spider-man the animated series
which aired during the 90s and
wrongfully i came away from that series
with the impression that venom was one
of if not the main spider-man villain in
the 90s i loved that power of the show
so much i actually got it on vhs and
broke the videotape by playing it too
much i mean the moment i walked out of
the theater after seeing spider-man 1
myself and my brothers wanted to see
venom in these films he was our favorite
villain albeit for childish reasons but
what can i say i was 10 years old and so
while i can absolutely appreciate that
sam raimi didn't want to make a venom
movie and that they shouldn't have
insisted on him doing so i can also 100
understand why the producers pushed him
into including that character i mean the
movie made more money than both
spider-man 1 and spider-man 2 on the
promise of venom alone so while i cannot
defend the creative decision that was
made whatsoever the producers did their
job they made sure the character the
fans wanted most was in this film and
that concludes my defense of this
decision because really i don't agree
with it at all from a creative
standpoint for a host of reasons so time
to break it down
you know
i guess one person can make a difference
enough said
better than i remembered coming out of
the theater in the summer of 2007 i was
left disappointed i was 15 years old and
having grown up to expect a certain
feeling from these films i was left
somewhat satisfied but given my
expectations for this film were sky high
thanks to the inclusion of the character
of venom one of the only characters in
spider-man's extensive rogues gallery
that i was familiar with it left me with
a sort of empty feeling fast forward 15
years i'm now twice the age i was when i
last laid eyes on this franchise and
when going through each of these films
thoroughly enjoying my time doing so
with each installment far exceeding my
expectations my mouse constantly hovered
over spider-man 3 putting it off for as
long as i possibly could not wanting to
once again spoil the good time i was
having with these films i didn't want to
repeat what happened when i was 15 years
old
and then
i watched it and what i found wasn't the
disappointment i experienced when i was
a younger teenager it wasn't the
infamous train wreck the internet had
been reminding me that it was it wasn't
a meme okay maybe it was a little but
you get my point when i watched this
film i saw something i never saw in this
film before
now take on this
i love this though it does have its
faults but it's nowhere near the
experience i was expecting it to be i
think if i was to say anything about
this film it's that it should stand as a
monument to how fearless the team behind
these films really were despite studio
intervention in truly exploring the
themes of responsibility in the first
film we saw what it looked like to
accept that responsibility in the second
we saw what it took to live with that
responsibility and all the sacrifices
that came with that decision and in the
third we see yet again the natural
progression of these ideas in the vanity
that comes with this unique
responsibility the poison that can seep
in through the cracks of your once
altruistic facade to create a monster
the villains one of the only things i
remembered about this film outside of
was that this film had way too many
villains and for the most part i think i
was
wrong now before you unsubscribe and
report this video for violent and
repulsive content hear me out because i
was actually shocked to come away from
this film with my mind having been
changed on that front let's go through
these quote villains
flint marco or sandman as he later
becomes known is a remarkably likable
character with righteous motivations
that over the course of his life just
made some bad choices choices that
ultimately ended up defining him he's a
character that sam raimi clearly had a
lot of time and respect for his
introductory scene demonstrates that
alone we see him running from the cops
ducking into alleyways climbing a fire
escape and into a young girl's room
a sick young girl's room he reaches into
his jumpsuit and he doesn't pull a knife
or a gun but a stack of letters for her
this is a father someone that's done bad
things in the past all in the name of
earning money to help make his daughter
healthy again and much like the rest of
reimy's villains he too can be defined
by a single quote
not a bad person
just had bad luck
and as the film progresses this bad luck
seems to follow him falling into a
testing facility and becoming imbued
with supernatural sand powers and due to
the choices he's made in the name of
doing right by and connecting to his
daughter those same choices might be the
reason he may never be able to connect
with her or protect her
ever again this is a man that has led a
tragedy of a life and i just adore how
his character is handled particularly in
the first half he's amazing also the cgi
around his powers rivals the stuff we
have today that scene where he walks
towards the camera as the sandman for
the first time and turns back into his
regular self is honestly seamless and i
do mean seamless i can't pick the
instance where cgi becomes real life
because it all looks real but okay
that's flint let's talk about harry
osborn harry does this weird face in the
film where he likes to open one eye and
have the other half open and he always
thought this looked weird but upon
watching these films numerous times i
think he was trying to look a little
like norman osborne under the influence
of the goblin but that's only a small
thing i noticed i'm a big fan of james
franco and he really had a lot of fun
with this role clearly i know that face
jokes aside though the slow progression
harry undergoes throughout this trilogy
of films is in every sense of the word
textbook from a negative change arc
standpoint and it's all the better for
it i think and with a film with this
many characters vying for screen time
his position in the film is helped
tremendously by the fact that he doesn't
need a long extensive scene to introduce
his character we've seen all the
underlying reasoning and plans we
understand his bad relationship with his
father we know the history we know the
misunderstandings we know what his
motivations are which is why his fight
with peter happens at the beginning of
the film and honestly it's an underrated
fight i particularly like the part where
peter was trying to avoid dropping aunt
may's engagement ring but then the
amnesia happens and this might be one of
my biggest issues with this film choices
like giving key characters amnesia and
random rocks with plot falling from the
sky to further things in the story or
allow certain plot points to happen are
i think inexcusable flimsy writing
choices choices that actively work
against what this film's message really
is all about but i digress none of these
or the parts they play in this story are
flawless none are as fleshed out or as
well executed upon as otto or norman in
the prior films i think so where am i
going with this well they didn't need to
be fleshed out or as well executed and i
think that's the genius part of this
film because the main villain of this
picture isn't sandman isn't harry
osborne or even venom
it's peter
gonna cry at its core this is a film
about choice
the beginning of which shows peter happy
it opens as all these films do with a
monologue but what sets this one apart
however is that unlike the others where
he carries with him a much more
melancholic tone in this he seems
thrilled to be spider-man almost smug a
smugness that causes him to become at
first oblivious and eventually
insensitive and later irresponsible with
the feelings and safety of those around
him and as his good times are denied by
mary jane eddie brock and eventually the
new surrounding uncle ben's killer he
slips deeper and deeper into this
indulgent desire for revenge eddie brock
with the venom symbiote isn't a
compelling villain really at all in fact
i'd go as far as to say that they are
the weakest part of the film if not for
the fact that the venom symbiote is used
much the same way doc ock's arms were as
a vehicle to exacerbate a pre-existing
urge within peter parker this symbiote
represents all the worst parts of peter
stripping him of his understanding his
kindness and eventually his
responsibility he becomes a monster
mary jane this was and still remains to
this day one of the only times a film
felt like it slowed down in time for me
the idea that peter parker would do
anything to hurt let alone hit mary jane
was a concept so far into where these
two characters began that the more i
think about it the more it makes sense
that this was the moment action and
choice that convinced peter that he had
become something unrecognizable
something he shouldn't be there's a
scene in the first film it's right after
peter saves mj falling from a balcony
during the parade the scene itself is
bright hopeful with those two characters
shot side by side sharing an intimate
moment the conversation ends like this
who are you
you know who i am
i do
you're friendly neighborhood spiderman
[Music]
but a lot has happened since those days
who are you
i don't know
though the question remained the same
the answer is now entirely different and
they are no longer sharing the screen
together the relationship between peter
parker and mary jane watson is an
awkward beautiful and tragic tale with
thankfully a happy ending personally i
think kirsten dunst's performance as
mary jane is spectacular and comes with
a quiet sincerity and vulnerability very
few actresses at the time could pull off
complemented perfectly by the character
itself at her core mary jane watson just
wants to feel like she's loved like
she's worth something in school she was
showered with affection there she could
be the person that she wanted to be but
when she came home
you're trash you're always gonna be
trashed just like her i have to go to
school
the one person she should be able to
trust screams at her and calls her trash
which is why this scene here makes me
tear up
i
wanna
act
[Music]
on stage
really
well that's perfect
this is mary jane watson this is her
opening up about something personal to
her expecting the usual reaction she's
always received from people and instead
peter shows her love i could talk for
hours about why i love these two and
their dynamic but when it comes to these
two as characters i love the contrast
that occurs in this moment in the bar in
spider-man 3. the person who was once so
loving so encouraging so considerate now
finds himself looking to humiliate and
in the process of doing so hurt the
person who truly understands and accepts
him for who he is it's a brilliant scene
i'm fine
i don't need your help
everybody needs help sometimes peter
even spider-man
the climax the interesting aspect of
this fight and really this entire
trilogy is that unlike the other films
which have set a precedent which states
that traditionally venom and sandman
should be playing the role of the
villains in this picture and indeed this
conclusion they are instead in large
part in this position due to the bad
choices peter has made right now both of
these individuals with their hatred and
determination to stop peter have created
the most visually imposing threat to new
york from this trilogy due to their
shared interest in peter parker off the
back of his symbiote abuse an abuse
which has led spider-man here unable to
protect mary jane unable to protect new
york city unable to protect himself
there is another hero in this film and
his name is harry osborne there's a
quiet scene where harry's alone
reflecting on what happened between
himself and peter scarred from the
encounter scarred from peter's hatred
within that quiet scene after those
events harry's butler bernard comes to
inform him of something he frankly
should have done long ago the true
nature of his father's fatal wounds the
act that defined peter parker in the
first film to not killed green goblin
now acts as the mechanism that brings
harry back to the light the good in
peter parker is what brings harry to his
side a brilliant contrast to venom and
sandman in this instance but his choice
in coming to peter's rescue off the back
of that information wasn't the only
thing i enjoyed about this section it
was his choice to come back from this
this is a very real attack unto harry
from peter despite it being in
retaliation to his own attempt on his
life harry felt justified and peter
never needed to go that far but did so
anyway similar to sandman and eddie
brock in this instance harry has every
right to feel as they do to embrace this
hatred for peter after the reasons he's
given them but he doesn't instead he
represents the most powerful part of
this film its final message whatever
comes our way whatever battle we have
raging on inside of us we always have a
choice my friend taught me that he chose
to be the best of himself it's the
choices that make us who we are and we
can always choose to do what's right and
in the end he does just that in an
effort to do the right thing he gives up
his life overall with everything
considered this film is still the
messiest out of the trilogy it makes
strange and at times unconvincing
choices in terms of its narrative and
above all else fails to utilize a fan
favorite character in the way that they
were expecting instead opting to use it
as a mechanism to bolster the themes of
this story with that said however the
symbiote absolutely serves a purpose in
this film by amplifying the incorrect
bad and horrible choices peter made the
story of sandman while glossed over
somewhat during the run time still feels
like one of the most human and likable
characters that while contributing to
the plot in a satisfying way reaches a
magnanimous conclusion if not in an
ambiguous fashion in the end both of
these characters instead of feeling more
like norman and otto's equals in this
trilogy felt more like a means to an end
in some respects which i think is this
story's greatest weakness too and that
is frustrating but with all of that
taken into consideration this film had
something really interesting to say
about the character of peter parker and
the lessons of choice that no matter how
bad things get everyone can choose to do
the right thing i found peter parker's
struggle against his darker tendencies
to be both poignant and at times
terrifyingly tragic i found the side and
background characters once again adding
to the stakes of each encounter the way
that only they can i found the
resurgence of harry osborn to be both a
wonderful albeit sad end to what
ultimately should be remembered as a
trilogy that while focusing on the
tragedy finds the light at all costs
when i was 15 i went in with an entirely
different set of expectations however
now at 30 going into this film with an
open mind i not only found that i was
wrong before but that i also had an
amazing time and felt as though that
this was a fitting way to end the
trilogy despite there being plans in the
pipeline for a fourth film that
ultimately never got made this is a very
special story to me one that i never
thought would match the gravitas it did
when i was a child
but man
was i wrong
recently someone decided to ask me what
spider-man meant to me and throughout
this video i hope i managed to give you
some indication
spider-man is my favorite superhero and
he's my favorite not because he's got
the best costume or has the best action
it's not because he has the best
villains or even the best anything
really it's because he represents the
very best and worst
of us
we live in a world full of suffering
much of which exists due to the selfish
and indulgent desires of those that
choose to make it that way the story of
spider-man while being a tale concerning
itself with the struggle of light and
dark isn't simply a fairy tale of black
and white it isn't about how wonderful a
person peter parker is or how terrible
those he fought against were instead it
highlights all of his worst attributes
his flaws his insecurities and his
desires plain as day so that we can see
him struggle against all of those
impulses because
it's the right thing to do
spider-man is my favorite fictional hero
because he represents mankind's greatest
quality
our capacity for good
that we are who we choose to be that
inside all of us is a hero
and that one person
really can
make a difference
enough said
[Music]
all right